do you feel like a man could be happy in
a marriage assuming a traditionally
female role let's say a stay-at-home
husband a man will most likely not be
happy unless he is fulfilling his basic
Duty as a man the duty that almost all
human civilizations have recognized
which is that you need to provide for
your family if he's the stay-at-home
husband the wife is out being the bread
winner it might be fine for a time but
the man's going to start to feel useless
he's going to start to feel emasculated
and the woman is going to struggle to
respect her husband cuz she's going to
start to see him that way too now your
marriage is on life support that's a
very very dangerous place to be I'm sure
there are people out there that have
done that and will attest that they are
happy but I do think that they're going
to be an exception to the rule